♪ MUCK.
MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S APPROVAL
RATINGS PLUMMETING TO NEW LOWS
THIS WEEK, NOW NEARLY 6 IN 10
AMERICANS SAY THAT THEY
DISAPPROVE OF HOW BIDEN IS
HANDLE HIS JOB AS PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT’S APPROVAL RATING
FALLING BELOW 40% THIS PAST WEEK
FOR THE FIRST TIME, THEN COMING
BACK TO 40.6 AS AMERICANS PUSH
BACK ON PROGRESSIVE POLICIES.
THIS WEEK VIRGINIA MOVING TO END
THE MASK MANDATES IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AS SEVERAL OTHER STATES
HAVE ELIMINATED MASK
REQUIREMENTS IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT AFTER AN
HISTORIC WIN IN VIRGINIA,
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WYNNSOME --
WINSOME SEARS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
MARIA, AND GOOD MORNING TO YOUR
LISTENERS.
MARIA: AND CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU ON YOUR FIRST VOTE.
I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THAT, WHY
YOU DID IT AND WHAT THAT FELT
LIKE, LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
>> YEAH.
SO MY VERY FIRST TIE-BREAKING
VOTE WHICH, YOU KNOW, I’VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET TO FOR SO LONG WAS
A BILL THAT WANTED THE JUDGES TO
SAY WHY THEY GAVE THE SENTENCING
THAT THEY DID WHEN THEY MOVED
OUT OF THE GUIDELINES.
FINISH AND IT’S A GOOD BILL TO
WANT TO HAVE EXCEPT THAT IT WAS
POORLY WRITTEN.
IT WOULD HAVE HAD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE ACTUALLY
COULD HAVE FORESEEN BEFORE IT
HAPPENED.
SO, YOU KNOW, I VOTED AGAINST
IT, AND SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY
YOU VOTED AGAINST THE SINCE CART
RACE9 -- INCARCERATED.
NO, I VOTED AGAINST A
POORLY-WRITTEN BILL WHICH WOULD
HAVE MADE BAD LAW, AND WE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO HAVE COME BACK NEXT
YEAR TO FIX IT.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU’VE WITHOUT TO
GET IT RIGHT -- YOU’VE GOT TO
GET IT RIGHT.
MARIA: THIS IS ALL PART OF YOUR
PUSH TO INSURE THE LAW IS
FOLLOWED.
AND, LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, I
THINK OUR VIEWERS THIS MORNING
ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
LAWLESSNESS THAT WE SEE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHETHER IT BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MANDATES OR
SMASH AND GRABS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE.
WHERE IS THIS LAWLESSNESS COMING
FROM, AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S COMING
FROM THE HIGHEST LEVELS, AND I’M
TALKING ABOUT FROM THE
PRESIDENCY ON DOWN WHERE THERE
IS NO LEADERSHIP.
THERE’S A VACUUM.
AND, IN FACT, THEY SEEM TO BE
FOLLOWING WHAT’S HAPPENING ON
THE STREETS.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO WORK FOR
ANYONE BECAUSE THE LEADER HAS TO
LEAD.
THAT’S WHY THEY’RE CALLED
LEADERS.
AND THEY HAVE TO SHOW THE RIGHT
WAY, THE RIGHTEOUS WAY.
THERE IS RIGHT AND WRONG, AND
YOU CAN’T LOOK AT WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN THE STREETS AND
SMASH AND GRAB AND SAY, WELL,
IT’S JUST SOCIAL JUSTICE.
NO, IT’S THEFT, AND IT’S
DESTROYING OUR ECONOMY.
WE’VE GOT TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
STOPPING, YOU KNOW, WHERE’S THE
WIND BLOWING, AND THAT’S WHAT
WE’RE ABOUT.
THEY FOLLOW THE POLLS AND THEY
DON’T HAVE A RIGHTEOUS BONE IN
THEIR BODY.
COME ON.
LET’S LEAD M -- LEAD.
MARIA: AND YOU ARE LEADING.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, I WANT TO
TAKE A BREAK AND ASK YOU THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION IN YOUR
LIFE AS WELL AS WHAT’S HAPPENING
IN OUR STUDENTS’ SCHOOLS THESE
DAYS, PLUS PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
PLEDGE TO APPOINT ONLY A BRACH
WOMAN TO THE -- BLACK WOMAN TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
IS AMERICA REALLY RACIST LIKE HE
KEEPS SUGGESTING?
>> -- WILL BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BECAUSE ARTICLE VI OF PROVIDES
NO RELIGIOUS TEST SHALL EVER BE
REQUIRED.
I THINK THE 14TH AND 19TH
AMENDMENTS ALSO EXTEND THAT TO
NO RACIAL OR GENDER TESTS.
NOBODY SHOULD BE EXCLUDED
BECAUSE THEY DON’T FIT A RACIAL
OR GENDER CRITERIA.
IF.
MARIA: THAT WAS LEGAL SCHOLAR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ WITH ME EARLIER
THIS MONTH CALLING BIDEN’S
CRITERIA FOR A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BIDEN HAS VOWED TO NOMINATE A
BLACK WOMAN AS JUSTICE STEPHEN
BREYER’S REPLACEMENT, AND HE
WILL BEGIN MEETING WITH HIS
SHORT LIST OF CANDIDATES THIS
UPCOMING WEEK.
I AM BACK WITH VIRGINIA
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WIN WINSOME
SEARS.
I’VE GOT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
WHAT’S TO GOING ON ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN TERMS OF THE MASKS
COMING OFF.
I KNOW THAT GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN,
USING EMERGENCY POWERS TO
EXPEDITE A BILL TO END THE
SCHOOL MASK MANDATES, BUT,
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, THE
TEACHERS UNION BOSS, RANDI
WEINGARTEN, IS SAYING THAT THE
REAL ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID RESTRICTION ARES IS MAKE
MANYING PEOPLE FEEL SAFE, NOT
THE ACTUAL SCIENCE.
SHE BELIEVES KIDS AND TEACHERS
SHOULD WEAR MASKS UNTIL THERE’S
ZERO TRANSMISSION.
IS THIS ABOUT POWER AND DISPLOL
TELL US HOW YOU SEE IT FROM
VIRGINIA’S STANDPOINT.
>> YEAH, WELL, SHE DOESN’T SPEAK
FOR THE US, SHE DOESN’T SPEAK
FOR THE PARENTS.
THE PARENTS VOTED FOR OUR
TICKET, THE PARENTS VOTED FOR
GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN AND MYSELF,
AND, BY THE WAY, THEY VOTED FOR
OUR HOUSE SO WE COULD HAVE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF REASONABLENESS
COMING BACK, YOU KNOW?
COMMON SENSE HAS WALKED BACK
INTO OUR GOVERNMENT HERE IN
VIRGINIA, AND VIRGINIA IS
LEADING THE WAY.
SO THE GOVERNOR FULFILLED HIS AM
PAIN PROMISE, AND HE -- CAMPAIGN
PROMISE, AND HE TOLD EVERYBODY
IF YOU WANT TO WEAR A MASK, WEAR
A MASK.
BUT ALLOW THE PARENTS TO MAKE
THAT DECISION FOR THEIR OWN
CHILDREN BECAUSE AS FAR AS WE
CAN TELL, MARIA, THE PARENTS
STILL -- THE CHILDREN STILL
BELONG TO THEIR PARENTS.
THEY DON’T BELONG TO THE STATE,
NOT JUST YET, NOT IF WE CAN HELP
IT.
MARIA: RIGHT.
>> SOME PARENTS FILED ISSUES
WITH IT, AND NOW WE HAVE A BILL
THAT’S GOING THROUGH, AND IT
LOOKS LIKE IT WILL FULLY PASS,
AND WE’LL HAVE A LAW HERE THAT
PARENTS WILL MAKE THAT DECISION
AFTER ALL.
MARIA: OH, MY GOODNESS.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, PARENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW ARE
ROOTING YOU ON AND THANKING YOU.
THEY ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
I CAN TELL YOU FOR SURE.
LOOK AT ALL OF THESE POLICIES
AND WHAT THEY’VE PRODUCED.
ON FRIDAY OIL PRICES PASSED $94
A BARREL.
JOE BIDEN ON HIS FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE KILLED THE XL PIPELINE,
AND WE HAVE HIGHER GASOLINE
PRICES AS A RESULT AND AND OIL
PRICES AT $94 A BARREL.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO IN
THE LEADERSHIP IN VIRGINIA TO
COUNTER THIS INFLATION THAT
AMERICANS ARE FEELING?
>> WELL, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING AND WE
HAVE STARTED DOING IS TO GET RID
OF THE GAS TAX, WE’RE TRYING.
I THINK IT PASSED THE HOUSE.
I THINK IT FAILED IN THE SENATE.
SO NOW THE HOUSE BILLS ARE
COMING OVER TO THE SENATE, AND I
THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEGINNING -- SENATORS ARE
BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND, THIS IS
REAL.
THIS IS REALLY HURTING OUR
POCKETBOOKS.
AND YOU MAY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
CARRY YOU THROUGH, BUT THE RANK
AND FILE DO NOT.
AND, BY THE WAY, I’M PART OF THE
RANK AND FILE.
I DON’T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY
EITHER, SO I UNDERSTAND THE
PAIN.
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE FOOD TAX.
WE NEED TO GET RID OF THAT.
EVEN THE OUTGOING DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT
HAD -- THAT WAS NECESSARY.
SO GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN PROPOSED
ALL OF THESE TO HELP THE PEOPLE.
AND, BY THE WAY, THE BUSINESS
TAX.
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE SUFFERED
GREATLY FROM WHAT THE OUTGOING
ADMINISTRATION, GOVERNOR
NORTHAM, CLOSED MOM AND POP
STORES, KEPT THE BIG BOX STORES
OPEN, AND IT’S DESTROYED PART OF
US.
SO SO WE HAVE GOT TO GET THIS
THING TOGETHER, AND WE HOPE THE
SENATORS WHO ARE DEMOCRATS WILL
WORK WITH US TO GET IT THROUGH
BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS SUFFERING.
IF.
MARIA: YOU ARE THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN ELECTED CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF
A U.S. STATE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S PLEDGE TO
APPOINT ONLY A BLACK WOMAN TO
THE SUPREME COURT?
>> I’M ACTUALLY SECOND IN
COMMAND, SO THAT’S INTERESTING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, HERE I AM
SECOND IN COMMAND OF THE FORMER
CAPITAL OF THE CONFEDERACY.
NO ONE CAN SAY THAT WE HAVEN’T
GOTTEN A LONG WAY FROM WHERE WE
STARTED.
AND FURTHERMORE IF, I’M AN
IMMIGRANT, YOU KNOW?
I WASN’T EVEN BORN IN AMERICA.
AND LOOK, AMERICA HAS GIVEN ME
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUCCEED.
NOW, WE HAVEN’T IS, YOU KNOW,
I’M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT WE
HAVEN’T HAD PROBLEMS.
OF COURSE WE’VE HAD.
YOU KNOW, SLAVERY WAS AN ISSUE,
AND WE’VE HAD RED-LINING,
SEGREGATION, BLUE CODE LAWS BUT
HERE I SIT TO SAY WE ARE NOT
BACK IN THOSE DAYS.
ARE THERE PROBLEMS STILL?
YES.
BUT HERE I AM, AND WE ARE
OVERCOMING, AMERICA IS BECOMING
MORE AND MORE -- WE HAVE A
SAYING IN CHURCH, YOU KNOW, I
MAY NOT BE WHAT I’M SUPPOSED TO
BE, BUT I AIN’T WHAT I USED TO
BE, AND THAT’S AMERICA.
SO WE’RE COMING BACK TO THE
JUDGESHIP, YOU KNOW, IT REALLY
ISN’T UNHEARD OF FOR AMERICA TO
PICK CERTAIN PEOPLE TO BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
YOU KNOW, WE DID IT WHEN WE
WANTED.
WE CLAMOREDDED FOR A FEMALE
JUDGE, AND WE GOT SANDRA DAY
O’CONNOR, AND THAT WAS A GOOD
THING.
WE CLAMORED FOR A BLACK JUDGE,
AND WE GOT THURGOOD MARSHALL.
THAT WAS A GOOD THING.
AND HERE EVERY WE HAVE SONIA
SOTOMAYOR, YOU KNOW, IT MIGHT
NOT BE THE POLITICS THAT WE
LIKE, BUT WE HAVE HER.
AND SO, AND THEN FOR THE FIRST
HUNDRED YEARS OF THE SUPREME
COURT’S HISTORY, THOSE PEOPLE
EXPECTED THE COURT TO BE
PARTISAN AND, IN FACT, THEY WERE
HIGHLY PARTISAN.
SO WHAT I’M HOPING IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL BRING US A JUDGE,
YOU KNOW, IF SHE’S BLACK, WILL
BRING US A JUDGE WHO RESPECTS
THE CONSTITUTION AND WILL UPHOLD
THE LAWS AND WILL NOT BE A
PARTISAN.
YOU KNOW, WHO WILL JUDGE FAIRLY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THAT’S WHAT WE
NEED.
MARIA: YEAH.
THAT’S WHAT WE ALL NEED AND WHAT
WE ALL WANT.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, AS YOU’RE
SPEAK, I’M GETTING THE KILLS.
WE KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
FOLLOWING YOUR JOURNEY, AND THIS
WILL NOT BE YOUR LAST STOP ON
THE JOURNEY.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, IT’S GREAT
TO HAVE YOU THIS MORNING.
PLEASE COME BACK SOON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND
PLEASE PRAY FOR OUR TROOPS
ALREADY IN TO POLAND AND, YOU
KNOW, I KNOW THERE IS A TIME FOR
PEACE AND A TIME FOR WAR, BUT
LET’S HOPE THAT WE DON’T HAVE TO
GO TO WAR.
MARIA: WELL SAID.